the Nintendo switch has been promised
lots of third-party support but that
doesn't mean every game will make it to
the system earlier this month
gearbox software CEO Randy Pitchford
said it's not likely that Borderlands 3
will come to the switch so what's up
with that speaking with glicks --all
pitchford elaborated on this situation
he said I think there might be some
scenarios where if the switch becomes a
place where there's a huge number of
customers and it doesn't compromise the
experience that we're making there could
be a scenario where us or take 2 and 2k
decide to take the effort to make it
happen but we can't really think about
that right now
in Nintendo I think wisely can't
prioritize forcing that to happen I
think they're better off Borderlands is
published by 2k games one of the third
parties supporting the switch so we'll
have to see what the future holds in the
meantime we have plenty of switch
coverage up on GameSpot and we'll have
even more as launch day grows closer to
keep up with all the latest be sure to
subscribe